pas d action directe cette étoile rouge
à cinq branches apparaît pour la
première fois en 79 attentat contre le
ministère du travail à paris
c'est le temps des cibles symboliques
banque ambassades sociétés
internationales action directe
si le groupe a choisi ce nom c'est parce
que dans sa première période son but est
d'agir en dehors des partis et les
syndicats
le gauchisme français s'étiole et se
terminerait l'année 74 75 et que cette
politique le gauchisme violent parce
qu'il décide de le faire de ce discours
pas sombrer dans le terroriste et que
c'est à peu près de ce moment là des
années 65 que les gens qui plus tard
vont faire actions directes commencent à
dire à l'action politique à la
conscience politique si on peut appeler
ça l'action politique et il son encontre
d un contre-courant un contretemps et un
contre société pour sortir de cet
isolement action directe cherche un
soutien hors de france
liaison avec les fraction armée rouge en
allemagne les brigades rouges en italie
les cellules communistes combattantes en
belgique
c'est alors le début de la période dure
1984 hold up de l'avenue trudaine deux
policiers tués meurtre du général audran
attentat manqué contre guy branagh le
vice président du cnpf assassinats de
georges besse le pdg de renault le
groupe préparait d'autres attentats
après la rafle de vitry aux loges on a
trouvé ici des armes des explosifs et la
liste de futures cibles alors la
question se pose ce coup de filet du 21
février 87 marque-t-il la chute d'action
directe
l'action clandestine requiert un certain
nombre de personnes on sait que pour
faire une filature il faut tant de gens
pour poser une bombe autant de gens pour
tuer une personne il faut tant de gens
et ce qui était fait au nom d'action
directe par les gens dont le noyau
central est et vitry aux loges dépasse
les capacités de travail de quatre
personnes même acharné même ne faisant
que ça donc il est certain qu'à l'heure
actuelle des complices des comparses des
gens
de la logistique par exemple sont sans
doute encore en liberté et il reste il
doit rester quelques plans quelques
appartements conspiratif comme dit la
police qui n'ont pas été trouvés il y a
quinze jours le juge bruguière
spécialiste du terrorisme recevait une
lettre de menaces signés action directe
canular véritable menace ou
l'utilisation du sigle il est trop tôt
pour savoir si l'étoile d'action directe
s'est éteinte définitivement